kevin o'leary your roaming investor in
the middle of Strasbourg France why do
you care because it's the center you can
use with the Parliament is this is the
epicenter where all the decisions are
made for your community now let's talk
about what's happened here because it's
been tumultuous the last year started
almost 35 years ago with just seven
countries today it's 23 not all of them
in good shape obviously during the times
of economic boom nobody care when things
got tight it became a mess countries
like Ireland Romania Portugal they had
billions of euros dollars if you want
pour it into them and of course their
economies blossom but they had a lot of
debt and now it's crushing debt and
countries like Germany are paying the
price not everybody's happy anymore I'll
tell you why there's a lot of
inefficiency in this apartment take for
example this store I've rented a band so
I can take my crew all over the place a
big Mercedes truck holds nine people 10
people so yesterday we get in it great
driver nice guy after two hours he pulls
over says oh I got to stop for 31
minutes I said quoi he passed the Albany
why are you doing that he said that's
the union rule I can't drive from other
two hours at a time
think about that he's got a meter
sitting in the truck that says exactly
how many minutes he's been working I'm
paying him while he's walking around
having a cigar police came by making
sure that he was there for 30 minutes
this is insane now this kind of lack of
productivity permeates entire society
such a huge balance between quality of
life which is good and making no money
which is bad which is why countries like
Greece ignore it is zero that's a
problem now personally I love to come
here drink the wine eat the food so I
want to try and make money here I don't
think so as an investor i'm kind of
thinking germany looks good to me
because they sell everything to
everybody but here's a new problem
globalization is hit this place so just
the time when all these countries like
Romania which have low cost want to make
stuff for people the Chinese hit the bus
stop at half the price that's why
they're rock walking around burning
everything around here they're unhappy
about globalization you know what I say
too bad deal with it maybe get that guy
that's driving the bus to finally drive
for three hours before it takes half now
having said all that tis the season to
be jolly so wait check this out Santa
Claus ready
ho ho ho Merry Christmas made in China
till next time kevin o'leary your
investor at large